[Musique]
une terre sèche brûlée par le soleil un
environnement qui ne pardonne pas
à cargui au nord du Kenya il fait 40
degrés à l'ombre
alors le Puy de Riri m'a offre un peu de
répit point de convergence des troupeaux
engagés dans une incessante ruée vers le
haut
la vie ici s'organise autour du puits
Ibrahim bourouillage vers le trafic et
c'est de s'assurer qu'il y est assez
d'eau pour tous les animaux assoiffés
autrefois fiable la terre nourricière
montre aujourd'hui des signes évidents
de faillite la sécheresse actuelle et
d'une durée et d'une intensité sans
précédent et les conséquences sont
terribles
Ibrahim ne fait pas exception son
cheptel n'est plus aujourd'hui qu'un tas
mais
quand même
dans la région des dizaines de milliers
d'animaux ont succombé en quelques
semaines seulement
one point d'artiste complet
clairement ici on est aux premières des
changements climatiques les données
scientifiques ne mentent pas dans
certaines régions du Kenya les
températures moyennes ont déjà augmenté
de 2 degrés plus inquiétant encore Dame
Nature se fait imprévisible les épisodes
météo extrêmes se multiplient
[Musique]
il suffit de se rendre à hurry Hills
pour avoir les conséquences connues pour
ces collines perdoyantes et ses riches
pâturages cette région du nord du Kenya
a toujours eu des airs de paradis
mais rebab aura n'aime pas y revenir
l'endroit pour lui emoji
[Musique]
car c'est ici que son troupeau de près
de 500 moutons chèvres et chameaux a été
décimé en une seule nuit l'oeuvre d'une
vie oblitérer en un instant
une tornade sans doute du jamais vu dans
la région tout comme d'ailleurs les
inondations soudaines en pleine saison
sèche qui ont noyé un peu plus loin des
milliers de bêtes un drame infini dans
une culture où la richesse se mesure en
nombre de de bétail
le vieil homme n'a plus la force de
recommencer il ne soit toujours nuit
plus qu'une chose pouvoir garder ses
enfants à l'école le plus longtemps
possible gage selon lui d'une vie
meilleure
comme lui des populations entières
d'éleveurs dépendent aujourd'hui de la
générosité de leurs voisins ou de l'aide
humanitaire
l'ONG local passida par exemple est très
active sur le terrain
et les points de distribution comme
celui-ci alimenté par camion citerne
sont clairement insuffisants we are to
give the water
les conséquences n'ont pas fini de se
faire sentir déjà la sécheresse mène à
l'exode et à des conflits armés
[Musique]
l'a déjà compris l'élevage ici n'a plus
beaucoup d'avenir en fait c'est tout le
mode de vie nomade qui est menacé
alors il prévoit se débarrasser de ces
derniers animaux et ouvrir une boutique
pour vendre des produits de première
nécessité la seule solution selon lui et
de s'adapter car la planète n'a pas fini
de se réchauffer